good morning John last week after VidCon
I went to Disneyland and was reminded
that like most children of the 80s and
90s and probably even today I grew up
knowing that this word was Disney but
not really understanding why like this
is not a D and this isn't really a Y
it's like gisnet why well John I had
some coca-cola and opened way too many
tabs on my browser and done a lot of
research and I found this story to be
very weird so your first get Wow my hair
so your first guess is that it's Walt
Disney's signature right and yet here's
Walt signing his name on an episode of
What's My Line and that doesn't look
familiar but it turns out that Walt
Disney had lots of signatures some of
them resemble the Disney logo some of
them do not but none of them have a D
anything like the loopy D I can imagine
this constant innovation on his
signature in two ways it may be just
another manifestation of his
perfectionism which was well known or it
may be a man who was pretty obsessed
with his own name but before we go any
deeper into this we have to discuss
something else very weird about the Walt
Disney Pictures logo for almost 50 years
there wasn't one every movie had a
different treatment for the title card
there was a Disney signature that with
slight variations showed up repeatedly
originally not as a logo but as a
signature after a statement thanking the
staff in 1937 Snow White in the Seven
Dwarves that signature was last used as
a title card in the rescuers in 1977 but
it was never identical to a previous
usage making it decidedly not a logo the
graphic design nerd in me feels like
this must be an intentional choice
because it was very contrary to how
every other movie studio was doing the
thing it's almost as if Walt and the
Walt Disney Company wanted there to be a
perception that this was a person
presenting it rather than a corporation
so the name is the brand not the
branding here is a man you can trust
to make children's content savvy after
the rescuers the Fox in the Hound used a
nondescript serif font almost like a
palate cleanser
before 1985's the Black Cauldron
launched with the now familiar loopy D
this was one year into Michael Eisner
taking over as CEO and becoming the
first person to run Disney who was not a
Disney family member now there are a
number of Disney designs that look
similar to this final incarnation that I
imagine will be in use until the
universe ends there
this from a 1950s Peter Pan board game
which matches the Disney logo almost
perfectly except for that D and then
there's this signature an actual Walt
signature that contains lots of the
elements that W the looping T the big
circle on the eye even the quick and
intense return on the S but that D
though where did it come from well the
closest I could find is in the final end
card of the Aristocats which came out in
1970 maybe importantly this was the
first movie Walt Disney Pictures
released that Walt himself did not work
on it's on the screen for like three
seconds but it's clearly as close as we
get to the loopy D before the early 80s
when Disney launched its home video
division using this familiar logo type
as the title card but in the box art the
loopy D soon that logo type with the
cinder of a castle and shooting star
would become the first actual logo of
Walt Disney Pictures so somewhere
someone behind the scenes in the early
eighties decided to make that little D
loop into a big bold spiral he pushed
that so far that the first letter and
one of the most iconic brands of all
time doesn't read clearly as a letter
under-eyes news leadership this clean
and playful logo type became the logo
type for the entire studio and then a
Disney Channel at Disney World and the
Disney Company as a whole and it's easy
to make it read more clearly as
london-based illustrator pencil bandit
made clear with these modified versions
but that's not what they wanted almost
all of this logo type was taken directly
from one of Walt's many signatures
except for its most bold iconic and
confusing choice but because Disney is
all about magic and magic can be lost
when you find out how it's done we
probably will never find out how this
happened or who did it maybe that's for
the best
John I'll see you on Tuesday